his law and Society fellow talk my name
is Sandy Irani and I am the associate
director of the Simon's Institute for
the theory of computing and for those of
you who are unfamiliar with the
Institute we are the world's leading
venue for collaborative research in
theoretical computer science The
Institute was founded in 2012 with a
generous Grant from the Simons
foundation and we bring together the
world's leading researchers and
theoretical computer science in in
related fields as well as fostering the
next generation of young scholars
um before we get started just want to go
over some Logistics so today's event is
hybrid so if you're sitting in the
auditorium here
um you can feel free to raise your hand
and ask a question and if you're
attending over Zoom you can type your
question to the Q a and I will see it
and can ask Jessica the question on your
behalf
um so the
um Simons Institute law and Society
fellowship program is a recent addition
to the Institute it was started in 2020
and having the lawn Society fellows here
enhances our programs in particular the
ones that address Technologies with
profound impacts on human society and
that have implications for ethics law
and policy and this semester we've been
really lucky to have Jessica Holman with
us today uh all semester long as our
lawn Society fellow
um Jessica is the Ginny remedy associate
professor of computer science at
Northwestern University and her research
addresses challenges that arise when
people draw inductive inferences from
data summaries she's won numerous awards
for her work including best paper awards
at top visualization and HCI venues
um she's a recipient of the Microsoft
faculty award in an NSF career reward
among other things her talk title today
is using theories of decision making
under uncertainty to improve data
visualization visualization so please
join me in welcoming Jessica thanks
all for coming
um so yeah I am the law and Society
fellow here
um and what I'm gonna talk about is a
lot of what I think about as a
researcher so
um you know I work in data visualization
and interfaces and you know I care a lot
about the role of summaries of data for
helping people draw generalizations from
you know samples
um and so you know when we consider the
role of data and judgment and decision
making we sort of have to care about
things like visualizations because they
influence you know what we get from data
sets or predictions that we get from
Models
um in settings from you know Civic
Behavior where we might look at election
forecasts plots like this and try to
make decisions about you know how much
effort or money should we invest in
trying to get our candidate elected
um to you know the scientific literature
where visualizations are important for
you know showing things like
experimental results for
um you know helping us understand what's
going on in terms of like deep uh neural
Nets and all this is you know helping us
Drive New research by trying to
understand the data that we collect and
so my core research program
um is not so much about law but about
how to design and evaluate uh you know
data summaries and in particular I care
a lot about how we communicate
uncertainty which is I think where my
work does connect more with societal
implications so
um you know people you know in general
in everyday life we're always being
confronted with data as well as in
science and so how do we help people do
things like make good effect size
judgments or separate signal from noise
how do we make sure that they update
their beliefs in sort of a rational way
given new information on some you know
parameter that people might care about
like some rate of disease how do we help
them do things like causal inference to
understand what affects you know
um you know things again like disease
rates and so
um you know I ask a bunch of questions
related to tasks like this I think about
different populations to some extent so
both lay audiences as well as experts
um and uh and yeah so what I want to
talk about today is this question that's
really sort of core to the kind of
research I do which is
um you know how do we design effective
visualizations for inductive inference
so again for people you know looking at
data and trying to generalize or
extrapolate to some larger population or
phenomena and so I want to start by
giving you a little background on how
this question is often approached in
research on data visualization or data
interfaces so um because I think it
might surprise you a little so one very
common approach for instance in
visualization research is to try to find
designs that maximize perceptual
accuracy and the idea is that you know
we're showing people data we want them
to read the data values accurately and
so we can do things like graphical
perception experiments
um you know which started back in
psychophysics in the 60s where people
would do things like show people in this
case like a chart where we have two
marked sections and ask them to do
low-level sort of visual tasks like tell
me you know what proportion the smaller
marked bar is of the larger and so the
idea is that by having lots of people do
tests where we vary the way that we're
encoding the data we can rank different
encodings and say for instance that you
know if you're showing quantitative data
you should not use like an area in
coding so don't encode your numerical
data as circular area because people are
really bad at judging that instead use
something like position in a scatter
plot or actually position in a bar chart
with a common axis because you're just
really looking at the position of the
tops of the bars and so
this works for for you know telling us
how well people read data but you know
optimizing for accuracy and perception
has some limits if we look at you know
people trying to draw inferences and
make predictions from visualizations
um so you know one problem we see is
that you know in an in a context like an
election we could show someone
um this election uh prediction
um and you know with a display like this
there's very little perceptual error if
we care about someone getting the
probability that each candidate wins um
they can just read it right there
um but just because they got the
probability with no error does not mean
that they're actually going to use it
rationally or to make utility optimal
decisions so for instance you know many
people I think see something like this
they don't know what to do with a
probability like 71.4 percent and so
they might use some sort of rule of
thumb like if this seems far enough from
50 I'm just gonna you know
um I'm just gonna round it up
um on the other hand you know we could
show them something that makes the
perception of the probability a lot
harder there's going to be a lot more
error like this animated gauge that the
New York Times used on Election night of
2016.
um so perceptual error will be higher
but they might actually integrate the
uncertainty into their decisions in a
case like this because it's hard to
ignore
um we also sometimes see people using
things like user satisfaction or
user-centered design so you might ask
people which of these two displays do
you find more effective chances are if
you ask people these kinds of questions
about representations of uncertainty
they will tell you they prefer something
like on the left because it feels really
easy to use it you can just sort of
ignore
um the uncertainty whereas this really
is hard if you want to ignore
uncertainty and you can't
so accuracy and perception doesn't
always work another kind of more broadly
framed objective that we often see is to
build visualization tools and design
visualizations to sort of maximize
someone's chances of finding patterns in
the data and so you know for example
judging from their features a lot of
these kind of like state-of-the-art
systems like Tableau Software that that
are kind of very dominant in market
share in sort of the data analytics
space are really sort of optimized to
make it as easy as possible to sort of
pick out the patterns so
um you know I can drag and drop
variables to shelves it's going to
recommend visualizations to me I don't
have to think about even what I really
want to show or how I want to plot the
different variables it's going to
aggregate the data by default so that
it's really easy to see Trends and
differences
um and so uh so yeah we sort of we sort
of care about you know just putting the
patterns in front of people this
obviously breaks down again for
inference so consider for instance you
know someone trying to explore data and
generalize to a population so they have
samples and they're using some visual
analysis tool and they want to say
things about the population from which
the samples are drawn we did an
experiment a few years ago where we
showed people
statistical Graphics that either used
aggregation or did not they saw samples
and they were asked to tell us you know
what would you conclude about the
population from these from these
different displays and everyone was
assigned to either aggregated data or
disaggregated data or disaggregated data
with a mean and what we found as maybe
you would predict is that when people
see aggregated data the way that they
talk about sort of effect size is
different so when we looked at the kind
of things they wrote down a lot of times
it was sort of as though they were
thinking about effects in this kind of
signal detection framework where an
effect or a difference or a trend is
either present or absent on contrast in
the disaggregated display conditions
people tended to talk about things like
the size of an effect the reliability of
an effect and so people were sort of
weighing the uncertainty or the the
noise relative to the signal we also saw
that when you show show people
aggregated data at least people who
aren't trained statisticians they tend
to be insensitive to sample size so we
could show them you know a visualization
of 20 points versus 2 000 points and
they're going to be equally confident in
what they conclude about the population
and so disaggregated data by default
sort of shows you the sample size
um and so to make sure that the
visualizations and the visualization
tools that we're developing you know
support inference from data I think you
know what I've sort of concluded is that
we need more robust objectives and kind
of these standard things that we use in
our Fields
um and you know I use the term robust
here in the sense of like robust the way
you would talk about a predictive model
where we want interfaces that perform
well or as expected despite changes in
the inputs or the conditions including
errors or misuse of the visualizations
whatever that might be and so you know
I've spent a lot of time developing
visualization techniques for things like
visualizing uncertainty as well as
interaction paradigms things like you
know how do we get people to think about
what their prior is for some parameter
before we show them data but what's
Driven a lot of my work is this question
of like what is the right objective to
design for when we approach a
visualization problem and some of my
work that I'll talk about today has
really driven me towards Theory which
sort of explains why I wanted to come to
Simon's Institute because I think
um to sort of really understand some of
of and answer some of these questions we
have to get a little bit more formal
um so I want to first talk about you
know trying to take seriously an
objective related to you know saying
that a good visualization supports good
reasoning under uncertainty
um and of course we have to make that a
little more specific and so
um you know one type of judgment that we
might think about when we're showing
people visualizations of distribution
whether it's for forecasting or in the
scientific literature is that people
should be able to judge effect size and
effect size here refers to basically you
know our ability to judge kind of the
distance between distributions but also
account for the
um or sorry the the location of
distributions but also account for the
scale
um so we want to sort of think about
like how big is the signal to noise
ratio and one way that we can you know
ask people to report their perceptions
of effect size individualization is
called probability of superiority and so
um this has been said to be sort of a
more intuitive way to ask people to
think about effect size we can ask them
like what's the probability if I take a
random sample from the distribution B
here it would be greater than a random
sample from a
um and so this is kind of a nice way to
think about effect size because I think
you know often we show people sort of
fixed effects um you know estimates of
fixed effects and it's hard for them to
always think about like what does that
effect mean at the level of the
underlying measurements and so
um here where we can imagine you know
we're sort of asking someone like if you
ran some within subjects experiment and
people you know did some tasks with and
without some treatment like if you drew
a random person what's the chances that
they benefited from the treatment
um and so one thing we might realize
though is that if this is sort of an
important judgment to do from
visualizations
um sort of standard statistical Graphics
we see used to express distribution make
it pretty hard
um so here you know if I want to answer
this question like for one I couldn't
tell if these are independent or
correlated random variables from a
static display like this is just
impossible to know but even if they're
independent like to answer this question
I sort of have to do kind of like
compute an integral so do basically do
like like area judgments people are
really bad at this I have to then do
some calculations on my integrals and
any kind of mental calculation usually
leads to error and so you know it's just
a hard judgment to do and it's not going
to be any better with with you know
other types of common representations of
uncertainty
um and so you know this is a very simple
example we just have two distributions
and so we could just plot the difference
um and then people could see this and
um you know they'd get more direct
information but the idea of
visualization that makes it sort of
challenging is that often you know we
don't want to assume that we know
exactly what people want from a
visualization so often we have
multivariate data and we want to design
visualizations without having to know
exactly what comparison someone wants to
make and so these are just you know two
random variables you can imagine my data
is more complex how do I support these
kind of judgments
um and so one thing I did a long time
ago has a PHD student actually actually
is trying to figure out like how would
we design a visualization display for
this type of judgment so if we care
about effect size as probability
superiority and so what we came up with
was basically like imagine you have your
observed data say A and B are you know a
treatment and a control in some
experiments we're going to generate
other sort of alternative reasonable
versions of that data set we might see
if we repeated data collection so here
we can fit a model to A and B and sample
from that or we could just do sort of
non-parametric
um kind of resampling with replacement
but we want to make sort of different
versions of the data that we could see
under the same generating process and
then we'll visualize each of them
um as as a plot
um and the important thing here is that
we keep things like the y-axis scaling
consistent because we want to we don't
want things uh the the scales changing
because then we can't compare these
things but after we do that we can sort
of put them together in an animation and
people can kind of watch the uncertainty
play out
um and they can get probability of
superiority now easily because you know
they can just watch How often these
these two bars change order
um and so this is you know okay maybe
for these 2D charts maybe you wonder
like is this really worth it but if you
consider all of the different types of
visualizations where the visualization
is more complex the data structure is
more complex
um these are the cases that are hard to
visualize uncertainty for because we
basically have to add new visual
encodings
um and that often breaks kind of things
that we like about the chart so one nice
thing about these hypothetical outcome
plots is that as long as I can generate
sort of reasonable data from the same
process
um and as long as I'm not using
animation already I can show uncertainty
for all sorts of things like you know
forecasts where we have state
correlations icon arrays if I want to
keep with like this frequency framing I
don't want to add like shading or blur
um and even things like you know uh
communities predicted communities and
social network graphs where we have to
think a little bit harder about how to
keep the scales things like the color
scale or the color assignment and the
node positions consistent but basically
we now have a way to show uncertainty so
so that's nice
um but in doing all this work I'm trying
to sort of think about how do we design
better visualizations for effect size
judgment one of the things I started to
become curious about based on sort of
experiments I was doing is how do people
make these judgments when they don't
have a visualization that really
supports it
um so like we talked about you know
things like standard density plots make
it sort of hard to do these judgments
um and so we did some experiments that
sort of gave us some clues about how
people
um and I'm talking about people who are
not really trained in stats here are are
estimating things like probability
superiority
um so in one of these experiments we
told people they were going to be in
this fictional Boulder sliding
competition so it was like a Winter
Games thing and they were sliding a
boulder on ice and they were trying to
get a higher score so that they could
beat their competitor and they had this
choice of whether they would use the
standard Boulder or a special Boulder
which would help them slide their
Boulder further
um and what we wanted to look at here is
you know what what's the difference in
how people perceive the effect size and
how much they're say willing to pay for
this this special Builder if we show
them inferential uncertainty so the the
uncertainty in the estimated average
sliding distance versus
um kind of measurement or predictive
uncertainties so the uncertainty of the
underlying
um you know distribution of measurements
um and so we gave people either a 95 cir
95 predictive interval chart and we gave
them the corresponding intervals which
are
um you know predictably uh you know
related if you have a gaussian
distribution in text so these were sort
of informationally equivalent except the
conditions varied based on which we
visualize predictive or inferential and
you know maybe someone has a guess where
what do you think do you think the the
probability superiority judgments were
the same
do you predict
No Maybe
sorry
so what is showing us the uncertainty in
the estimated mean on these like your
sliding distances for these Boulders and
one is showing us uh kind of the the
variance in the underlying distribution
so it's 1.96 the mean plus or minus 1.96
times the standard deviation or the mean
plus or minus 1.96 the standard error so
it's basically a confidence interval
versus what you would call coverage or a
predictive interval
so what we saw which maybe uh is not
surprising if you think about
visualization but it's maybe more
surprising uh here is that people were
much more likely to overestimate the
effect size with the inferential
uncertainty so
um you know we had them tell us the
probability of superiority we asked them
how much they'd be willing to pay for
the special Boulder and we actually also
elicited how they perceived the
underlying measurement distributions and
all of these were much more likely to
overestimate um sort of predictability
of an effect size uh on the left
um and so one thing this made us wonder
is like well what are people doing that
makes this chart lead to such different
responses
um and so one thing that we tried was
like well maybe maybe people see how how
visually distance how visually distant
the two distributions look on the far
left and maybe they're somehow mapping
that to effect size and so we've we did
another condition where we showed them
the 95 confidence intervals but we we
change the X's scaling so that they were
seeing
um the the score change implied by the
actual measurements um and so we found
that this attenuated the bias like it
went down in terms of effect size
judgments and willingness to pay
interestingly all of no matter what
condition
um they saw people were overestimating
effect size in all of these so we could
help them a little with this
um they didn't do quite as well as they
did with this still but it had some
effect but they're still people are
still overestimating this and so I mean
these results are consistent with people
paying attention to things like visual
distances and perhaps between the means
of each distribution and then using that
as a proxy for effect size and so
um so if this is what people do when we
show them you know visualizations of
distribution
um that's kind of interesting to know
about because you know maybe we want to
try harder to design against this
um the previous study I just showed we
hadn't actually set out to um to see
what strategies people were using and so
we did a follow-up study where we wanted
to look more directly at like the extent
to which people are looking at things
like visual distances when they see
uncertainty or distribution so we set up
a task in this experiment where we
showed people some true effect sizes in
terms of probability superiority so
that's the x axis here and then we ask
for their responses
um what did they perceive the
probability of superiority as and then
we can compare sort of curves that we
fit to their data so each person is
going to do multiple trials and see
multiple ground truth effect sizes and
we can fit sort of functions that
describe the amount of bias in their
perception of probability of superiority
so you know if you're just reporting the
ground truth it's going to be a diagonal
line if you're relying on some sort of
heuristic that looks at things like
distances you're going to see something
closer to an s-shaped an S shape so
you're basically you're over
overestimating you know probabilities on
the small end of the scale and
underestimating at the higher end and
the way we set up the task was that
specifically we varied the standard
deviation in the visualizations or the
distributions we showed them in order to
to produce situations where the if
you're using some sort of mean distance
like you're looking at the distance
between the means of each visualization
or each distribution
um you would do better at high variance
than at low variance because at high
variance it's going to be a better Q for
effect size
um so here's what this looked like
um basically like I said we had two
different variance levels so we're
showing people distributions
um two different variance levels in the
distributions that they're shown but we
kept the the axis range consistent
um and so in this case we're again sort
of telling them to think about this kind
of sports scenario so we're telling them
you know you're playing a fantasy sports
game you have this choice of whether you
want to invest and pay to get a new
player on your team we can show you
predictions of how your team will do in
terms of score with the new player which
is red and without and your goal is to
sort of you know get a score above some
threshold because if you get that you
will win some award
um and so like I said you you know if
you're relying on the distance between
the means and sort of maybe normalizing
that by the total y or the total X
distance here
um you know you're going to do better at
a higher variance
and so in each trial people are
estimating effect size in terms of
probability superiority and then they're
also making a decision do I want to buy
the new player
um and for this we could Define sort of
the optimal decision rule which was uh
to invest in the new player if the the
score difference was above some
threshold
um so we were interested like I said in
you know to what extent people were
relying on these strategies and we
thought maybe we could make people more
likely to rely on these heuristics if we
manipulated the charts in such a way
that we made the means a little more
Salient to them
um and so in the top here you know we
showed everybody saw they were assigned
to one of four different types of
visualizations but everyone saw some of
those visualizations without any
additional Mark to show the mean and
some with a mark to show the mean and
the idea was that you know when you show
people central tendency they kind of
over fixate on that and in particular
like I said
um these hypothetical outcome plots were
kind of you know a visualization that we
designed specifically for this type of
judgment and so we thought you know know
we could like cleverly show that like
when you add a mean to these things you
drastically change how people use them
um because you know they'd start using
this heuristic
um so that's not however what we found
um the results of this study um which
ended up winning the best paper uh were
kind of surprising to us so one of the
things we found was that across the
board everywhere people appeared to be
relying on distance heuristics um it
didn't matter if we annotated the means
and in fact even for the hypothetical
outcome plots which we expected to be
the most different if you annotate the
means
um there was very little difference and
what luckily we had asked people to
describe
um what strategies they were using to
make these judgments and what what we
found was that for instance for the
hypothetical outcome plots 85 roughly of
people were doing exactly what we didn't
want them to do so the people who didn't
see the means annotated they were
watching you know the draw for each
random variable they were estimating the
mean of each random variable and then
they were basically just like you know
looking at the distance between the
means so that's like the exact opposite
of sort of the optimal strategy and so
it it was sort of interesting because
you know it took us several studies to
to realize that this kind of thing can
happen we also saw um that a lot of the
differences that we saw between
visualizations although we were able to
estimate them we did um I've skipped
over the details but we specified
Bayesian regression models
um that accounted for the full
experiment structure so we modeled all
the interactions between these different
manipulations
um and we got some differences that were
reliable but they were very small it
seemed like the visualization didn't
really matter that much
um and so you know this these results
got me sort of thinking more about you
know what are the challenges that we
often run into when we're trying to
study these types of problems where
we're interested in showing people
uncertainty um and we're trying to
evaluate how to do that better
um and so you know for one uh there's
this issue where the prevalence of these
heuristics makes it hard to know when
you've designed a better representation
because often the optimal strategy you
know for some tasks is going to produce
a response that looks the same as the
heuristic and so it can be hard to sort
of distinguish when do we have one
versus the other case
um and so you know this is sort of
interesting because like if the optimal
strategy and the heuristic performs
similarly it would kind of imply that
the visualization doesn't really matter
that much
um and I think often the visualization
does matter it's just that like if we're
using probability superiority as the
objective it's not quite capturing that
um and so one sort of uh line of
follow-up work um based on all this
um is that you know it's gotten me
thinking about like what is an objective
to design these representations of
uncertainty for that is less agnostic to
the strategy someone is using
um and I'm not going to go into detail
about it today or present any results
but one idea is that whoops there's this
nice connection
um between the idea of doing a posterior
predictive check in a Bayesian
statistical workflow and a good
visualization so a good visualization is
one that helps you compare your
expectations about data to The observed
data and so in some way work I'm trying
to sort of formulas formalize this idea
of like comparing predictions against
observed data as kind of a thing that we
can design for
um like I said I won't talk about that
I've written a paper about that if
you're interested
um other issues that this kind of study
got me thinking about so another is that
you know as in most behavioral
experiments we have kind of noisy
responses from people so people you know
respond within and across them there's a
lot of variants if you ask them the same
question
um but on top of that in visualization
experiments you know we're dealing with
some inherent stochastic stochasticity
um because we're generating samples
often from some data generating process
and so there's some inherent Randomness
there and if we're not directly modeling
this it can be hard to know like when
are we likely
um to see an effect and when is when is
any given effect likely to be sort of
swamped by this this randomness
another problem that sort of keeps me up
at night related to experiments like
this is that I think they're sort of
inherently optimistic
um so whatever an experimenter is doing
an experiment of the type that like the
experimenter had some hunch about
something that would help people
um and they go out to test it it's
almost like you're kind of morally
obliged to study whatever your
intervention is or whatever you think is
going to help under conditions that are
most likely to show you some some
difference because you know if you think
something's going to help people um like
I think people are going to do better on
some task with some particular
visualization I'm not going to go out
and find people that you know are
already doing perfect on that task I'm
not going to go out and find people that
no matter what I show them it doesn't
matter they always respond randomly like
I'm going to look for the situations
where it's likely to matter and I think
in visualization research this manifests
as sort of choosing or defining the
range of stimuli that we test in sort of
a narrow way so it's like we're zooming
in on the the range in which we think
we'll see an effect
um I think this happens in all sorts of
experiments all the time and it often
gets overlooked
um and it's actually fine I think as
long as when we interpret our results
we're very careful to say like this is
conditional on this small range I think
what uh the problem I see including
people interpreting my own research is
that often the interpretations are
unconditional so they say you know
people see a study and they're like oh
this visualization did better than this
one and therefore I should always use
this visualization and so that's
problematic
um and in visualization I think one nice
thing is that we can actually model some
of this this laziness
um we can try to you know be more
specific about how we might be zeroing
in on things but all of this implies you
know we need better ways to reason about
how much a better representation or a
better visualization is likely to help
in a given decision problem so I'm
talking here broadly about you know
problems related to some sort of
judgment under uncertainty and so these
questions have pushed me to think more
about Theory and so I want to talk now
about some work I've been doing um in
collaboration with some colleagues uh
theorists um so yifon Wu and Michaelis
Mama Coast are Theory students at
Northwestern Jason Harline is my
colleague but the idea is that we're
going to try to formalize the value of
visualization in a decision setting
and so um there's two points you could
say that which we might benefit from
reasoning about the value of a better
visualization so one is before we run
any specific experiment so before we
show people specific data samples and We
Gather behavioral data we might want to
reason about like you know how much
value might a better visualization of
uncertainty in this context
um add
um and so we can think about like what
are baselines we could compare to even
before we've gathered data another time
that we might want to do analysis is
post experiments so we've shown data
some or some shown some specific data
samples to people we've gathered their
behavioral responses and maybe we now
want to compare
um to sort of some theoretical kind of
expectations to make sense of what we
got in the behavioral data and the
approach is going to be to use
statistical decision Theory to reason
about visualization problems
um both pre-experimentally and
post-experimentally
um and so in order to do this we have to
define a decision task first and so I'm
just going to do this for the KLA all
paper the one that I just presented
um on the the mean distance heuristics
and so here the state that's uncertain
that people care about is whether
um you know in the next game that's
played um the team with the new player
would win
um and so uh that is uh that score
difference so we have a score with the
new player drawn from some normal
distribution with a mean of variance and
a score without
um the new player similarly drawn from a
normal distribution the same variance
across these two distributions and Theta
is one if the score with the new player
is greater than the sport without so
that's the sort of information that the
participant cares about
um we're asking them for the probability
of superiority the true probability of
superiority can be defined here it's you
know we essentially get it from the
difference in means divided by the pool
and Sample variance and we can think
about the prior here which I didn't talk
about when I briefly went over this
study but basically we sampled eight uh
ground truths probability superiority
values between 0.55 and 0.95 to do this
experiments and so the prior would be
like knowing that we took uh you know a
draw from these from this discrete
uniform distribution like what would you
report as your probability of
superiority which is the expectation
over that
um and so we're going to ask people to
report you know what they perceive as
the probability of superiority and
um and then we need a scoring rule
basically to to tell us kind of you know
um the payoff that someone gets or the
stakes of getting something wrong um and
so what's interesting is in our original
experiment we incentivized the decisions
the effect size decisions people had to
make but we did not even incentivize the
probability superiority judgments and so
um so it's interesting sort of you know
to think about how much does this matter
um but here we're going to assume that
we'd use like a quadratic scoring rule
um just to analyze this problem
and I should state that like if you look
at a lot of uh experiments on
visualizations and interfaces even the
ones that involved you know reasoning
under uncertainty it's very hard to even
pull out this basic information about
like what decision problem is being
studied so
um it's I think very uncommon to even
you know Define things like a scoring or
use a well-defined scoring rule in these
experiments so it's sort of interesting
to think about that and what that means
about the results that we get when we
test
um interfaces if we haven't quite fully
defined our problem
um so given these definitions or this
decision problem
um we can do some pre-experimental
reasoning as I mentioned about the value
of a better visualization in this
particular task
um and so one kind of
pre-experimental call we might want to
make is roughly like when our study is
when is our study dead in the water
um and so this is kind of related to
doing like a power analysis if you do
experimental research where you're
trying to determine the sample size that
you need in order to to detect an effect
of a given size
um and so generally people do power
analysis if they're using like a signal
detection framework or a null hypothesis
significance testing but you don't have
to only do um you can do
pre-experimental analysis without using
you know significance testing
um the idea is that you know you might
want to know when your expected standard
error um from your experiment or your
study design is larger than the effect
that you're trying to detect
um and so Andrew Gelman for instance has
written about how certain psychology
experiments for instance um by uh uh
kurizawa here
um are kind of dead in the water because
the experimenter is setting out to test
some effects so in this case
um kurzawa does a lot of studies to look
at how predictive different social
factors
that things like characteristics of new
parents are to affect the sex of the
children that they have and so these are
experiments where you know if you look
at prior data the expected effect in
sort of probability of having a girl
versus a boy in any subpopulation is
going to be very small like less than a
one percentage Point difference however
you know you have a psychologists
running experiments on like a couple
thousand people and so you're sort of
you're you're not going to be able to
detect uh you know a less than one
percentage Point difference because your
standard error if you you know come up
with an uncertainty interval is going to
be like 10 percentage points and so this
is the kind of thing that we can do
pretty experimentally but we want to do
this for visualization studies and so
um you know we could do a traditional
power analysis but it's kind of annoying
to have to need a prior on the the
effect size
um we'd rather not have to assume that
and so in this case we're going to use
the rational agent which we can kind of
draw on when we have visualizations or
if we have a dado problem and we're are
going to use that and the definition of
our decision problem to sort of do some
yard sticking so we can roughly Define
dead in the water here as the case where
the rational agent gains little
information about the problem from the
visualizations that they're shown
so let's start by setting up a scale for
different types of Agents here
um so in the case of the rational agent
here we might consider them with the
visualization as kind of our upper bound
so so they're going to use the optimal
decision rule
um they're going to look at the
visualization and going to report their
response we might want to compare that
for instance or well first let me pin it
down to the kale paper so for the kale
paper if we're talking about a rational
agent with the visualization we had we
call these four different visualizations
but if you consider the rational agent
who's going to use the optimal decision
rule these are going to be equivalent
um we're going to assume that the
rational agent can watch the animated
hypothetical outcome plots indefinitely
and so uh so the upper bound is going to
be the same kind of for the rational
agent with any of these visualizations
um we might then want to ask so what if
the rationally or what if you had an
agent who just had the prior basically a
rational agent who was given the prior
but no visualization like where would
that fall
um here uh and the scale again is
scoring rule which is quadratic which
you know implies a scale from zero to
one and so we might want to know you
know before we run the experiment is the
rational agent with prior going to be
pretty close to the sort of Maximum
possible score you can get or is it
maybe is there more room for us to sort
of see potentially differences
um from a better visualization
so we can do this for the kaleol study
so the rational age
here gets a score of 0.832 if we think
about the prior we had these eight
ground truth effect sizes
um you were uniformly likely to get any
of them the prior implied by that
actually puts the score very close to
the rational agent with the
visualization so there's we've already
sort of learned that this study is on
some level at least with a quadratic
score and we're all kind of dead in the
water there's not a lot of room to see
differences in here
um and so you know at this point we
might consider our design again we might
consider you know should we Define the
problem differently should we maybe use
a different scoring rule um one that
better separates these things
um uh and so you know these are the kind
of design questions that we could ask
ourselves
um in this case you know we ran the
experiment
um and so post experimentally we might
want to also do some analysis and so now
we're going to try to rank the different
behavioral responses that we got and
compare them to these these different
sort of baselines but first i'm going to
normalize the scale so the rational
agent with the prior is now at zero and
the rational agent with the
visualization is at one and so now we
want to take the behavioral responses
and and somehow compare them
um one of the challenges in doing that
with behavioral data is that you know we
have to account for the experiment
design
um so you know in this case we had this
kind of complex experiment designed in
the the KLA all papers so we had people
doing repeated measures so the same
person gave us multiple judgments across
different ground truth effect sizes we
also had a within subjects manipulation
where some charts showed the mean and
some charts did not annotate the mean
and so basically in order to kind of
compare our behavioral responses we have
to account for all for these design
things because the rational agent you
know it doesn't matter what order they
see things in if they're always going to
give the same response but for a
behavioral agent things like the order
in which you do trials or see
um visualizations Can matter uh and so
um luckily in this case we had uh at
Bayesian regressions and so these are
inherently generative models and so we
can basically generate responses from
our posterior predictive distribution
and we can uh kind of marginalize over
the nuisance parameters things like the
order effects um the random effects of
individual subjects and so we can rank
the behavioral visualizations or the
behavioral agents with visualizations
and when we do this we would hope maybe
that we see them between the the
rational agent with the prior and
um you know the rational agent with the
full visualization
um so is that what we see uh not in this
case
um so I'm going to give myself more
space on the slide um because when we do
this with the different visualizations
in our experiment one thing that we
observe is that most of these
um are doing worse than the rational
agent with the prior
um and so you know we see kind of the
same ordering um that we saw in the
original results the dot plots with
means do better for probability
superiority judgments and
um the hypothetical outcome plot to do
kind of the worse
um but this is sort of interesting this
idea that
um you know we're doing worse than the
rational agent with the prior
um so I think one thing we can conclude
is that you know we didn't give people
the prior and that's probably kind of a
mistake because now when we try to do
this kind of ranking we don't know like
are people far from the optimal response
um because they don't have the prior for
the problem or are they far from the
optimal response because they're
behavioral and they're doing something
weird
um and so one thing we might do is you
know go back and run this experiment
where we give people the prior and then
we see you know do they do any better
with the visualizations but
um you know this is kind of this this
interesting
um uh you know uh property we have of a
lot of disease visualization experiments
where the the prior is not always well
defined or it's not given to people in
this case I honestly think if we re-ran
the experiment and we gave people the
prior probably things would not change
that much
um just because in this case remember
the response skills 50 to 100
um the ground truth effect sizes are 55
to 95 and the expectation or the prior
is going to be around 75 and I think
when people do an experiment like this
they're shown data they're they're
basically you're probably going to
assume a uniform prior over the response
range
um but it's still technically it's a
it's sort of a flaw in this work
um so uh you know doing this kind of
analysis we realize this
um so when a behavioral agent with some
visualization does worse than the
rational agent another thing we might
wonder about is you know uh you know
even assume we gave them the prior and
they still did worse is it that they
didn't get any information from the
visualization or is it that they didn't
use the optimal strategy um to report
the information they got
um and so you know one way we can try to
distinguish this is we can take our
behavioral responses
um and you know we know the ground Truth
for these behavioral responses like we
ran the experiment and so we can use
kind of the correlation between the
ground truth and the response we got for
these different conditions to uh Define
a calibrated behavioral response for
each type of visualization
um so here this is basically
um you know how how it sort of reflects
how much information is contained in the
behavioral responses so if you knew the
ground truth and you didn't get the
visualization but you got the response
the people gave you
um you know how how much better do you
do so the calibrated responses have to
be better than the rational agent with
prior
um but you know seeing where they fall
you know it looks like there's still a
long way to go in terms of people you
know getting the information from the
visualizations
um and so uh you know this can it gets
us thinking that's sort of about you
know
um why is it that people are still
pretty far how do we improve their
ability to get the information from the
visualization for instance
um similarly we can add things like a
heuristic to try to again make sense of
the behavioral results we got
um so here I talked about this mean
distance heuristic I never quite defined
it formally but imagine here people are
using a heuristic where they look at the
distance or the difference in means
between the scores that they see in the
visualization and then they divide by
something like the total score range so
the total range in the visualization
that's shown so they're sort of mapping
this or this becomes an effect size
judgment or a probability judgment if
people are using this kind of heuristic
like strictly we see that they do way
worse than the rational agent with the
prior and way worse than the behavioral
responses and so
um you know this is also sort of
interesting to think about because it
implies that like even though you know
people reported using these mean
distance heuristics whatever they were
doing you know it's not that they were
ignoring the variance information
completely like they were getting some
information
um it wasn't as bad as like totally
ignoring everything but the means um and
so
um so yeah so this kind of you know
framework I think can help us reason
about
um things pre-experimentally and post
experimentally and I'll just say sort of
anecdotally as someone who's done
different experiments um you know I'm
particularly excited about the idea that
we can calibrate the behavioral
responses to reflect on how much
information people got about a test so I
have other papers that have also won
awards
um one of which you know we had people
do a causal inference task so we showed
them data so we basically showed them
like contingency table data and we asked
them to tell us which of two possible
models that produce that data what was
the probability that they would assign
to each and so the two models were
different dags representing different
possible causal models where in one
model there was a treatment effect there
was a causal effect of a treatment and
another there wasn't and we had people
do this task and their responses were
terrible and so
um what was interesting when we looked
at how they described what they were
doing it looked like or it sounded like
they were often looking for the right
things in the visualizations it's just
when they responded on the probabilities
like it was way off and so
um in that paper we concluded like
people are just bad at this causal
inference task and no visualization
seems to help them
um but I think probably if we went back
and did this kind of calibrated analysis
we might find that like they're they
were getting some information if they
were using reasonable strategies
um it's just that somehow there's like a
breakdown when they have to go report in
a probability scale so so anyway as
someone who does experiments I think
this kind of analysis
um allows us to think a lot more deeply
about what these effects that we
estimate actually mean
um and um just before I wrap up I want
to briefly highlight you know there's
other applications I think um where we
can bring in sort of um other types of
theoretical models to directly ask
design questions for things like
representations of uncertainty
um so for one other application we're
working on right now we're starting to
think about this core visualization
question of like how do I decide when
and how to aggregate the data um so
different visual analytics systems
currently use different defaults like
summer will aggregate your data by
default others will show the raw data by
default and so you can imagine a
designer might want to think about you
know different data conditions
um different possible visualizations
that differ in kind of the amount of
information they provide
um and ask questions about you know for
different scoring rules for different
data generating processes like what is
the cost of the worst aggregation
um and so in this case because the
visualizations differ in information
like they would differ to a rational
agent we're essentially relying on
Blackwell ordering to we basically have
visualizations
um some of which are like a garbling of
the others um and we can do this kind of
like again like without running any
experiments we can try to answer these
visualization design questions
um one thing I'm kind of excited about
with this
um or that I'd like to work on with this
kind of work is rather than thinking
about these individual judgments which I
think is a little unrealistic if we're
thinking about people doing visual
analysis I think it'd be interesting to
think about you know how do things like
aggregation choices affect sequential
analysis processes so things like Palm
DPS might be interesting here I think to
sort of model you know how does the
effect of seeing data aggregated versus
not affect like what you go on to do in
a visual analysis process
um so I think there's lots of
opportunities to formalize things that
people doing interfaces research are
sort of grappling with but but in a not
well-defined way
um so to summarize yeah I think this
this intersection between uh
visualization and HCI or in theory is um
quite productive I have other projects I
didn't talk about that also deal with
theory in other ways or where Theory
might be brought to bear but I'll just
wrap up by saying you know I think what
is interesting about a lot of these
problems that I see um in my field of
visualization is that there's these kind
of big open questions
um related to this ambiguity
um when it comes to sort of what types
of inference problems we should be
trying to address with interfaces better
interfaces and which types are not worth
kind of the effort of worrying about the
display and so I like to think about
this anthropic principle and stats which
is sort of loosely defined or colloquial
colloquially discussed but the idea is
that if you're going to do statistical
modeling there are certain problems
where you want to do it and certain
problems where you you shouldn't even
bother
um so if your signal to noise ratio is
huge you don't really need to do
statistical modeling
um if yours your data is so confounded
relative to the amount of sort of signal
or pattern in it
um you know that you're hopeless with
modeling like don't waste your time so
it's really this this Middle Ground
where you know statistical modeling can
help us and I think when it comes to
visualization
um you know and what what's a sufficient
problem for visualization I think we
would probably all agree in the fields
that you know when the signal to noise
ratio is huge then visualization
suffices like we don't need any other
type of analysis
um but I think there's these really
interesting questions that we we haven't
defined well at all in the field about
you know when do we think someone uh can
just use visual analysis when we're in
this middle range when do we think like
visual analysis will help but this has
to be followed up with like collecting
new data Etc
um you know are there some problems in
the space where visual analysis is
enough
um and I think there's lots of sort of
real world problems that come up that
have sort of made me want to answer
these questions so things like you know
for years we've been designing visual
analysis systems that sort of suppress
uncertainty
um we don't really worry about it so
much and you know in some ways these
things must be working and so what is it
that we're lacking in terms of how we
think about these problems that doesn't
allow us to explain things like
sometimes you know showing people
uncertainty doesn't really doesn't
really change things or doesn't really
improve what they're doing so anyway I
think there's lots of room to formalize
these things so I'll conclude there
um I have to thank all of my current and
former PhD students my student Priyanka
is here for the quarter I didn't get to
talk about her work but we do
differential privacy work interfaces
work together
um so yeah thanks for your time and I'm
happy to take any questions
thank you
foreign
is there
um any uh sort of clear-cut bad design
practices for visual visualizing
uncertainty
um yeah I mean I think error bars so I
didn't talk about any of the results but
there's over the last 10 years there's
been many studies showing that like even
you know people who use error bars in
their research
um often fail to connect them to things
like statistical significance so
um you know people think they can use
these rules of thumb about like whether
they overlap or not
um a lot of times people are wrong about
you know what that means
um there's other biases like in Lay
people so if you show people an error
bar on a bar chart like they tend to
think that the bottom range of the error
bar that's on top of the bar represents
like a more probable set of values than
the top of the error bar because it sort
of kind of looks uneven like that so in
general air bars are I think often the
worst you can do and it's also just hard
to explain like to a layperson what in
what a confidence interval which is you
know sometimes what we're showing means
you know we're making a statement about
our confidence in the method that
produced the interval not in the
specific interval and so
um sorry yeah that that I feel
comfortable saying is is not a good
choice ever
it's for these other things where you
know I start to question like how much
does it really matter
um because often people are using these
heuristics
um that make things look similar even if
you have you know what should
theoretically be a better visualization
um but in general I didn't talk about it
too much like the hypothetical outcome
plots I showed we talk about these as
like frequency based uncertainty
representation
um and so there's a lot of work in like
cognitive psych for instance um going
back to like the 80s where people found
that if you want to help people you know
do better on like classic Bayesian
reasoning tasks you should frame
probability as frequency so don't say
like 80 of the time say like I don't
have 10 times and so some of the work in
my lab
um has tried to look at like how do we
make uncertainty representations that
use like a frequency or discrete framing
to help people think about probability
um and so actually the study I showed we
had the hypothetical outcome plots which
are one way of doing things with
frequency we also have uh used a lot
these quantile dot plots and these ended
up doing best in this particular study
but it's basically just like a discrete
version of the density and weirdly we
find that like when you ask people
probability estimate questions or
incentivize decisions they tend to do
better just from this simple trick of
like making the representation discrete
um
so yeah that's a short
uh
what we've learned
thanks for the talk I just wanted to add
an example that I wish you could have
tackled everybody the cover of this
month's Wired Magazine covers the cover
story is about
uh pharmaceutical startup in San
Francisco that claims to be able to uh
give your dog your pet dog a drug that
will extend its life
and in the article there's no there's
they never mention anything about
distributions or confidence intervals
all they say is
breed X lives the 10 years and this drug
will make them lose the 14 year yeah no
and that's incredibly common like I have
a paper actually called why authors
don't visualize uncertainty um which is
based on this like The Economist Chuck
manske has the term incredible certitude
that he uses to refer to how it's like
sort of normal in the media and in
government reporting even to just like
present the estimates without
uncertainty so it's like we're like
incredibly precise
um uh and yeah I think like that problem
is really interesting like why we are
okay with that and I think some of these
questions I want to ask about like when
does it actually matter to have the
uncertainty kind of get at that I think
we don't you know there's these whole
arguments about like standardized versus
unstandardized effect size
um and I feel like there's still a lot
we haven't understood about like when we
should care and when we shouldn't um so
yeah no I see those examples all the
time um and they bug me but they bugged
me less than they used to because
because I also see that like sometimes
it doesn't actually matter if you show
the uncertainty so
thanks
question
thank you for the talk
if I understand correctly you assume
independency between the two population
when you wanted to
uh estimate POS in your experiments yeah
those were all independent just because
I mean it's not really fair to show
people static plots if there are
correlated yeah so my question is that
how hard or easy should be when we want
to incorporate dependency in
visualization
I mean I think I mean that's one of the
reasons why we use animation so we can
show like true you know multivariate
samples
um in general like I mean if you know
what kind of you know if it's like low
dimensional data and people care about
correlation they'll use like heat Maps
or things like that so you would
generally just switch the visualization
type
um you know if you cared about like
joint probabilities the problem is that
when you have these more complicated
displays where you have many different
variables and people might care about
many different joint probabilities then
it's just hard to visualize like we just
don't have good techniques um and so
that's where like the hypothetical plots
are really meant for these more complex
cases
um uh where there's just no way to get
joint probability information from a
static display you have to like know
every possible query in advance
if that helps at all yeah thanks for the
question
yeah I have a question so um do you use
animation Chloe is there a role for
interactive displays is that useful yeah
um
sometimes it works or sometimes it helps
and sometimes it doesn't
um
you know in general I think I'm a fan of
like simulation I think a lot of people
benefit when they can drive something
themselves even you know so I want to
like this stuff we're doing with model
checking so we're basically trying to
build visual analysis tools that let you
sort of check implicit assumptions you
might have about like the causal
relationships between different
variables and there I think you know
it's very powerful to be able to sort of
say like I want to see predictions from
a model like this and so people interact
a lot with this um this like model back
end that we have um
another but another in other places
we've seen like we think interactions
should help and it actually doesn't so
we you know I mentioned this other paper
we did um where we had people do these
sort of causal inference tasks where
you're trying to to determine is was
there a treatment effect and we had
causal inference tests of varying
difficulties and we showed people you
know uh visualizations of sample data
and there we did have some displays were
interactive because we thought like if
you can cross filter things you can see
like how many people have the Gene and
how many people you know have the uh got
the treatment and um you would think
they would help and they didn't help at
all basically so it's I think it really
a lot of it depends on what do people
know what they're doing I think um and
one of the hardest things I think is
like for me to realize that like I
designed this visualization that I
thought was like the optimal way to like
not let people use heuristics and like
they still if they don't know what
they're doing they're going to use it in
the exactly wrong way and so I think
this that's one of the hardest parts is
like how do you get people to understand
how to use some representation correctly
um well I imagine interaction could
actually hurt sometimes sometimes yeah
because people start clicking around and
actually some people have started
calling like visual analysis tools like
Tableau which really is about like just
show me the patterns um you know P
hacking machines because you have all
this flexibility to to look at your data
in all sorts of different ways and I
mean if you think of someone doing like
null hypothesis significance testing
visually then you know of course they're
going to find something with a large
data set um I'm not sure that that's
really as big a problem as we think
about I think the fact that like in
visualization research and interfaces
research we often don't think about like
what is the payoff of making a better
decision like I think a lot of times
when people do like they're like
business analysts are doing visual
analysis like they're only using it
maybe for lower Stakes problems like it
there's all these questions that without
formalizing things I think it's just
like people rely on their hunches which
bugs me
yes uh hi Jessica a fascinating talk
introducing this area so like
anecdotally one area where I always
complain about visualization is like
weather forecasts and like for example
you know I'll see it's like 50 to rain
at five o'clock 50 to rate at six
o'clock but I have no idea if these are
like negatively correlated with where
there's like a cloud yeah it's like
positively correlated where there's a
cloud it's either going to come or it's
not going to come yeah and you also have
no sense of it if I check again three
hours later will I get a more updated
forecast you know yeah I'm wondering if
you've ever thought about like yeah I
mean I think weather forecasting is hard
like the people I know who have like
looked at that domain I think in a lot
of these domains actually where we're
dealing with lay people there's
something called deterministic construal
error that people talk about which is
basically like no matter what you show
people no matter how you show them some
sort of uncertainty they're going to
think that it's deterministic and so
with like I know with weather forecast
if you try to show them things like you
know the uncertainty and the predict
predicted height temperature people you
know no matter how clearly you try to
label it there's a strong tendency to
see it as like the low and the high for
the day and like the the hurricane
forecasts they use this cone of
uncertainty and it shows you know an
interval around like the projected
hurricane path but people interpret it
as the size of the storm and so I mean
weather forecasts yeah like uh you know
people don't understand what the 50
means like they think um my student was
actually saying she read something about
like you know people think like it's
raining 50 of the area
um and I yeah like the correlations I
think I wonder about that stuff too and
I mean there was like a company dark sky
that I think was doing a better job with
some of the uncertainty representations
I think they got acquired but
um yeah it's a space where I think
people have given up trying which is
kind of unfortunate
um so yeah maybe meteorologists have
their own displays that they just won't
let us use
well thank you all for coming I
appreciate it